tristan tyler blake
welcome back we're back in l.a
we are in l.a now yeah closer to san
diego i have a theory you're
uh coming closer and closer to the uh to
the scientific oasis
yeah the richness
of southern california's topological
network of
genius is so saturated and we're only in
the beginnings
of exploring these diverse nodal
clusters of brilliance i'm
just so pumped so pumped i'm fascinated
to look into the history you know i
study
ancient rome and athens and uh
i see the birth of a new you know an
empire of kindness
you know or maybe a kingdom of kindness
right and uh
and i'm always interested in the people
that plant the seeds
who are who is our pericles who is our
uh you know the people that planted
these seeds into the ground that are
currently
pulsing with um with with inspiration
and and that is attracting people and
and cities do have gravity
yes san diego pulled me in and i hope
it's pulling you as hard
yeah yeah it's a great way to
to visualize it there is a massive
gravitational pull
and it's usually catalyzed by those that
are planting the seeds and watering them
that enable the growth
of these flowers that have these aromas
that are
attractors for the cross-pollination of
these new nodes to arrive and
give birth to these ideas huge huge
there's a there's a profound synthesis
also that's yet to happen between norcal
and socal at a deeper level marrying the
silicon valley
with the entertainment dissemination of
memes
and so if those two can sort of
synthesize at a deeper level california
is the sixth largest economy
in the world as a state by itself and so
we have a work to do here in the state
including the
san diego where we can and central
valley which is the agricultural
heaven also the fruit basket the planet
yeah
because it's a third of all of our
vegetables in the u.s come from there
and two-thirds of all our fruit and nuts
come from there let's let's rock it into
i love the theme of the episode
screenshots of imagination
out of out of everybody
that i know that is sort of obsessed
with
the idea of systematizing creativity
accelerating creativity maximizing our
ability to use
these technological tools that are so
democratized now to actually be able to
take those screenshots of imagination
and then turn them into these
beautiful creative projects that we
execute in the world
you're actually doing it because a lot
of high-level genius
talks about this process but you're
actually doing it and we'll
we have a really good demo to show you
we have a couple cool things that we'll
be showing you
before we unpack that let's head into
the journey specifically within the
journey
what made you who you are today to be
pursuing the star
that you care about so much no well i
believe every every journey
uh begins with an invitation so i want
to kind of invite you to do some
push-ups with me
i love it you know just let's let's get
active
and push ups and and this is this is not
only for us this is if you're out
there at home yeah do some push-ups i
love it boom
one two three
four five six
seven eight nine
10. tristan's at like 25
everyone actually
that that's a great feeling though
tristan's at like 40.
no no no he's literally at like 40.
i'm not even joking he might be at 70
now
i usually hit 17.
there's a and now he's doing wide grip
ones
i think he might be getting to a hundred
soon
it's pretty inspirational i love it i'm
already jacked from 10.
wow now the knee kicks
yeah yeah exactly what's our next squats
abs yeah
yeah now you're probably yeah now you're
probably really ready for the
for the show yeah i love starting
meetings like that yeah
as the team gets right at the beginning
and it's like
i love that i love that but what's
also important is after you work out to
capture your breath
too
so how fast can you re-stabilize your
breathing
um and i like to experiment with this
and to try to
catch my breath you know because one
thing that covett has taught us is that
breathing
is a um is a luxury
so when you recognize that and when you
wake up in the middle of the night
if you're a smoker let's say and your
lungs are you know full
and it's hard to breathe you start to
recognize
the the power of breathing
the the actual privilege of breathing
yeah
and that's why i quit smoking hookah
yeah
about a year and a half ago yeah you
know
and and i used my technology
infrastructure to support
my new habit or at least the loss
of a previous habit yeah
yeah 20 000 breaths a day and
the more awake you are the more you
realize that they come from the
photosynthesis of phytoplankton and
trees
that that's where the o2 comes from and
the more that you connect to that the
more you realize the whole of everything
the oneness that unity god consciousness
and
it's actually quite amazing because then
you basically leverage that
as a channel to all of the creativity
that you do in the world
so yeah take us into the journey
yeah so and thank you for joining me for
that invitation i love it
you know this
journey starts at my history we'll get
into this in future episodes
to truly uh parse the history a lot of
it is missing
um a lot of it's been lost over time
multiple lifetimes right three lifetimes
now
rotating you lose you lose things along
the way
in fact i was telling a friend earlier
today that i've lost
more in this lifetime than most people
have ever had
and and when you realize that and you
kind of sense
i've lived for a hundred years through
books
movies uh through my own experiences
when you live at an intensity that that
i experience right in a resolution which
takes in a lot of data you have to learn
what to do with all this information
it's it's overwhelming
yeah if your metabolism isn't trained
right to take all of that
high quality nutrition that data and if
there's a lot of bad data
and some of the things that we are
learning today is that
what we were taught in schools and even
at home
it has been to the best of our time
we've done the best with what we had
but now we have true clarity on
certain scientific concepts right
computational sciences have
revealed to us the nature of our reality
to
to in many respects um and
and it's a blessing right now to to be
able to search
this search engine of not only the
internet but our own unconscious
yeah which is a search engine right
it it computes and processes and you're
the one that
delivers the answer you're the external
device
on a on a machine which is hidden from
you the complexity of your mind is
is uh masked from you this dark geometry
going on inside of your mind
you think right now but you don't know
what are the the underlying components
that compose these
um marvelous thoughts
yeah so it sounds like within
where you
came from and where you are today you
sort of see it as
a big amalgamation of
complexity and data that you're
beginning to scratch the surface of and
dive deeper into the
iceberg that's below the surface and
that's
that's a profoundly important analogy
for us to all
really aim to truly become gnostic
individuals and beings in that sense
and yet today's computational
infrastructures
enable a decent amount of the beginnings
of that process
the early adopters the early adopters
you like yeah so tristan will definitely
be
unpacking how he's trying to rocket that
especially the visualization and the
creativity and all these types of things
and so then would you say that that was
sort of the
the formation of your north star
mission was really around seeing the
depth
of the computational renaissance
enabling the visualization and the
higher resolution of these datas so this
is quite a recent development i mean i i
picked up on uh machine learning
uh when i was still uh in new york this
was about four or five years ago
i saw that something was changing and it
would uh
it would transform our society and and
our lives
and i wanted to know what what it was
out of curiosity uh but before that i
actually studied the humanities and
uh did a lot of traveling uh around asia
around the middle east around europe um
and and i studied
kind of esoteric topics religions
different spiritual you know systems um
more as an anthropologist and kind of
amateur historian
a lot of ancient greek mythology which
gave me a lot of context and also a lot
of tools a tool set
that i could use to um
to repair my traumas
and i had a have a lot of traumas from
childhood
that i had to repair but i picked up on
the fact that technology could be used
to assist me in in
uncovering truth and on and recording or
capturing beauty yeah when i found it
i found a lot of ugliness in this life
and i found a lot of
beauty and uh and i've learned
to to distinguish between the two
and to select for one of them so all of
these demons
that you know they still haunt you but
if you know how to find
love and compassion and beauty and and
these
other elements these other
spirits sometimes they walk right into
the room with you
and you drop to your knees it feels like
your whole body goes cold
like like you can't move and
and these spirits pass through you
spirits of history uh spirits of uh
literature
uh spirits of death right if you've ever
met death
alone in your room and i've met it
two or three times okay
you come away with a new appreciation
for uh sunshine
and and one more single breath yes is
enough
yes to make it all worth it all of the
struggles
one more breath one more breath
yeah that makes a lot of sense that you
had that
sort of synthesis background across
different
planetary spiritualities philosophies
areas of knowledge and you also saw the
machine learning renaissance happening
and that that fusion makes a lot of
sense on
your background yeah and i think
instinctively so i was pulled
to san diego um uh
in my past when i was a little bit
younger i i was running away from
something
this might be a theme potentially of my
of my current
i mean this this week right um i
recognize that
i no longer run from my fears i run
towards my fears yes uh i've recognized
over these past experiences that behind
every fear
that's where your passions hide
like they play hide and seek from you
childhood
fantasies and and desires they hide
behind your fears and the moment that
you
unlock that fear that you that you
mature through it
you you your trauma disappears in that
area and it uncovers a childhood passion
that
you once wanted to explore
but you were you were cut in that
whether through a
a relationship that was toxic or
some kind of you know just trauma which
which
stuck with you throughout your life
and i i'm not afraid anymore i'm not
afraid of anything
yes which yes which has allowed me to
pursue my passions without resistance
[Music]
and and i think that's also another
theme that i've been discovering in the
silence of the last you know
few months since kovit hit um um
i've been alone for for quite some time
and and in that
um alone time i recognized that uh i
have the
opportunity to think and to clearly uh
hear
my own ideas my own
my body i got to listen to my body so i
started dancing
yes i started listening to my
to music to sound and and i actually
bought a guitar
the other day so i intend to
start playing that yeah so yeah so fears
uh they
they once you figure out a way to
approach it um if you have a methodology
you can
you can overcome your fears and i i
guarantee you will always find a treat
at the end
something waiting for you that you've
been waiting to find a very long time
yeah the north star is beautiful
in that when we take these
leaps of faith especially running
towards fears
that we're usually gifted with
incredible treasures on the other side
and we must see that archetype
and we must see it across the millions
of people that have lived
and that it's a such a common perennial
one that it
hopefully can land in everyone's hearts
today in modernity after seeing all the
trials and errors of people in the past
and
hopefully that that's how we can
one of the ways in a in a psychological
and spiritual sense
uh achieve the the gifts at the same
time we need the
from that place as we do pursue that we
usually end up
like i was saying a little bit ago we
end up being a channel for
some of the highest morals ethics these
types of things
and then everything we architect
regarding this computational
renaissance everything we architect is
there's no moral or ethical issues that
come with it
and i think this is a really interesting
example
with what you're showing us with synapse
because
what's what's happening is that right
now people feel this
exclusivity they feel exclusion in a
sense it's a
exclusive stakeholding because you have
we all have the
all of the social companies
that have an asymmetric relationship
with the users
where there's a
very
extractive style relationship of my
psyche
and that there's no there's no real
co-creation
in the process and there's no and it
would be
as one of the examples that i use a lot
it would be so beautiful to be able to
have data interoperability between all
the companies
leverage machine learning to find the
profound insights across all of the data
and then be able to visualize that on an
individual basis
for what profound ways that i can
increase my longevity
increase my north star success increase
my enlightenment and this is really the
ethos of chapter six ai coach and high
level perception
and that that right there also happening
on a planetary level it being scale
invariant where a country can see that
data
in sight and the planet can see the data
in sight
the way your architecting synapse makes
me feel like
it's a co-creative relationship with the
users it's not an extractive one it's
not
based on uh the monopolization of
asymmetric data control
things like that and so that's actually
a key i think
insight is as we become more fearless
and run towards those those
barriers those adversities those tests
of faith
leaping into our north stars we usually
find these massive gifts which is we
become better
architects of the more beautiful world
that we all want to live in
actually that's one of my primary goals
is not only to
provide people with this technology but
to
actually teach them how to architect it
themselves the basic principles
i don't want them to be limited to my
applications so i have several
apps that i've that automate aspects of
your life they
create an external memory bank and a
connection with
the universe or with other technology so
one collects my to-do lists and
there's a fairly intricate program
management suite behind that one of them
collects my
social relationships and that goes off
of my uh social networking research
so at home i believe people can invent
their own labs
and uh you know create essentially
research
applications to see how do people react
to
certain certain data certain um
psychological
experiments you know everything is
experiments so
you get to architect these social
networks at home
in your homemade laboratory and i
believe the next generation of labs is
going to be
feet away from your kitchen inches away
from your living room it's your computer
it's your vr headset right yes
i love the vision that you have we're
not just
giving fish we're teaching how to fish
and
the creative unlocking that's going to
happen by doing that process is massive
it would be like
an analogy is basically like if any of
these major tech
giants had a again a co-creative
relationship with the users
where there was more of a inclusive
feedback
loop on the creative explorations of
what the technology is actually possible
of unleashing
and so i love that because by empowering
the
the architect themselves the conscious
agent themselves to unleash their
creativity given the fact that you
actually give them the tools
and the curriculum that enables them to
do that creative process
that's way more in a sense empowering
than the asymmetric relationship we were
talking about earlier one of the things
that
that i'm fascinated to explore is so you
give this to a high performer somebody
that's really kind of
very high performance as is and how much
will this
boost their productivity by their time
management how much time will it
save in order for them to reuse it on on
creative or computational tasks rather
than organizational or structural
architectural tasks and
you would on people underestimate how
much time they spend
looking up uh information over and over
again
that's right um so so the you know this
high performer
it will increase their productivity and
then the essentially the
compound interest on on the time they
save over a lifetime could
uh create a massive amount of of
creative potential
but for people that are everyday users
and not let's say super users or not
uh hyper kind of productive people um
it will just help them make shopping
lists
uh little lists of you know hey i wanted
to buy my mom
a bouquet of flowers and the only the
delta between
them actu them thinking that and them
doing that is they have to open an app
they have to type it in they have to put
it in the right place and tag it or
catalog or register it and then they
have to execute it and
this kind of stages of you know from
um from idea to action there's several
steps involved and and i believe
this entire process can be consolidated
into
a you know a uh uh a double click
and it opens up some kind of you know
technology
and i will show this on the screen a
little bit later it captures the idea
and then you
rapidly catalog it where it belongs and
the example i want to use for that is um
when you wake up and let's say your
house is dirty uh
if you want to clean it 60 to 70 percent
of the of the of the pile up of the
socks or
whatever um if you had the ability to
click it and send it to the right bucket
right away let's say the laundry basket
60
of your problem is probably one or two
items
and then three or four other ones are
very selective highly
detailed kind of specific thought where
you actually have to do some creative or
or you know contemplation and if
my goal is to let people focus entirely
on the computational side
and user uh um you know cognitive search
engines to solve those kinds of problems
and let the organizational or structural
parts be a methodology
rather than something people have to
reinvent every single time they want to
clean the room which is
the current state of affairs
i like how you provide this
visualization
for people of the s procedural steps of
this process
where you call it a you call it a delta
from
the thought of wanting to embark on some
sort of a
process and that there being these
multiple steps along the way that
actually gets you to the
the output of what you want to
successfully do and the consolidation of
that
into the thought action boom that kind
of thing
is very much so the biotech neurotech
future that we're talking about with
things like neurolink which will
unpack a little bit more in a bit
but the most i think
a very friendly example for people also
is especially for those that
have websites this is a very common one
is that we spend
i would say it might be somewhere around
two
days per year on
website management as in needing to deal
with
the domain needing to deal with the host
needing to deal with the whoever you're
using for the design space
all these pieces and if maybe the
card information didn't get processed
one time and the site goes down and then
you have to spend a half day on the
telephone with the organization to get
everything active again
all these types of things so the point
being that
that's one activity
and that's two days per year potentially
of time that's only one activity
yeah and so there's potentially dozens
of these structural activities that
occur
that are not actually creative
and they're more of the foundational
that you've already done five times in
the last five years you've already spent
two days a year the last five years
doing this
stop we need to stop we need to make the
architectures that enable us to stop
doing those so we can spend the time on
the creative so it might actually be
something like
a month a year or something on all of
these
imagine what it would be like to have a
month when i'm standing in traffic
i think not about kind of the time not
about oh you know there's traffic
but i i go all of these people have
their time being wasted that's right and
and and
we could it's being stolen from them by
uh
by this organization by essentially you
know bureaucratic kind of inefficiencies
yeah uh and uh i would love to give this
time back to people
so that they could spend it on
themselves or on others
and and one of the interesting concepts
that i wanted to kind of develop is
so this project right from from concept
to creation essentially
uh that delta uh sometimes this project
is just a bucket
uh it could you know we'll talk about
quark park a little bit later today and
uh that's a bucket that i'm i'm
collecting ambiently throughout the day
i'm collecting
insights concepts brand ideas whatever
it is
and i'm throwing it in there uh
throughout the day
i actually currently don't have to you
know if i recorded the idea and i
had to parse it for its quality and and
truly tag it
uh that would be too expensive
computationally on
a minute-to-minute basis but i just have
the
ability to throw concepts into the
appropriate buckets
so think of it as a digital backpack
with near infinite
scalability and just you throw ideas in
there and you
just tag them enough to know where to
find them later yeah
so you can collect well how much how
much
how many ideas can you host at the same
time what's your hosting capability for
projects let's say
you often find people that are at
maximum capacity with the projects that
they're currently working on and
and you realize that that's a time and
computation
problem that's that's information manage
that's information system
kind of uh uh block
i see yeah so this is interesting so the
whole idea of being maxed out on
projects there's room to actually have
more but yeah and we're just not
accessing it because of all the
fundamental
things that are repetitive that we're
doing yeah that's an interesting
perspective and then the other one that
sort of came up that
i thought could be really interesting
for what you were saying was that
it's another super relatable one you
bring up when
we we're talking about this with zeb
kroll on the show who's
uh one of the la's up and coming music
producers
and he's so obsessed about
creating the absolute best ambisonics
screens chairs inside of autonomous
vehicles because
he wants people to have the peak level
of experiences of creativity focus
meditation
bliss joy peace all those emotions when
they're gonna be in ten years
sitting inside of the vehicles that will
enable us to be
in different states of mind than
stressful driving
and so he's thinking like we're
unlocking literally potentially
trillions of hours on a planetary
level yeah of time to do non-stressful
driving uh but to do creative so this is
the scale of
of that we're talking about also one
last thing there's a creative tax that
we're paying right now
for incompetence that's what it feels
like creative tax for incompetence
i like that a lot too that's a good one
i like that one
that's a good one and in a sense it's
also yeah creative task for incompetence
so let's use this in the wild creative
tasks for incompetence
repeat it again and actually well this
is yeah repeat it and i'm going to show
you what that
creative tax for incompetence so you see
even in a fraction of a second if i was
alone
i might have uh i might have lost that
insight and i believe and trust me when
you're walking down the street and you
have that brilliant insight
it could be next to you know you're just
walking down the street and you get that
uh um idea go ahead see
you think you're going to remember it
that business idea that will eventu
is inevitably going to emerge um you
know that that thing that you wanted to
do ah you forgot about it
well uh with a system like this now you
can capture those things and
i'll work on this later after this
interview but it's
here and it's not going anywhere like a
bunny just
popped out we had a cat on the car just
like a bunny pops out
think about this every time you want to
pull out your phone and take a picture
of that beautiful bunny
that that beauty that just emerged from
the from divine nature
by the time you whip out your phone and
go to your camera app
the bunny is gone yeah the same thing
with inspiration
same thing and that's why it's
screenshots that's why it's of
imagination and inspiration
that's right yeah 100 amen to that
because we're
a lot of us that are hyper creative are
swimming in the ocean of ideas and we're
trying to anchor
these ideas inside of our execution
strategies
but that they're swimming away so
quickly so
i also like the idea of the
just tacks on incompetence in general
because that can also be thought of like
where
in the autonomous vehicle example or in
if you look at the golden gate bridge or
the bay bridge in the bay area as well
we basically have or the la freeway
systems in new york all these different
cities across the planet as well
the idea is that about a hundred years
ago or so
we were realizing that that vehicles
were going to be transporting humans
but that we saw that there were
approximately
one out of every however many people
that was uh uh it was a much larger
amount of people
that did not have access to vehicles
back then and so this
the roads were built for that foresight
for just a couple of maybe a decade
or two down the line okay maybe more
some more people will get cars
but now where such a large portion of
the population owns motor vehicles for
transit
our actual roads as elon talks about he
talks about it being a two-dimensional
grid
and but we build up in buildings in
three dimensions
and so then that's our big problem and
so that's why boring's trying to go
down because then you have a
three-dimensional structure underground
as well for that
and so that style of foresight though in
terms of
not paying a tax i don't want to pay the
tax
on our creativity which is that we're
sitting in cars stressed
because we didn't have the foresight to
think guys maybe we should be monitoring
the amount of data of cars being
purchased across the planet and
upgrade our road infrastructures that
style of thinking and the same
style of thinking can be thought about
with things like why is brazil
and congo right now being short-term
incentivized to destroy
the rainforest and the biodiversity in
order for short-term economic growth
we can actually create a better
long-term economic growth mechanism for
them to preserve the biodiversity to
preserve the rainforest in the area
and to gain greater economic flourishing
in other paths
but we need to have that indigenous
seven generation principle
that will actually enable that yeah and
and this entire concept like
transportation energy infrastructure
this goes into
a a taxonomy i call a synthetic
infrastructure
it's a biologically driven uh um
infrastructure in the city which
breathes the wires breathe the city
the city breathes with you it it it's a
biological life form
and uh you know that's why the the
blockages and the arteries are what
traffic is yeah yeah yeah yeah
exactly um you know ancient egypt i mean
they'll like
the legacy of their civilization they
left us the pyramids and and
athens left us you know the parthenon
and uh kind of
what what will we leave behind what what
is the uh
uh the ode to civilization and and i
want to i i think that we should
have a little bit more ambition today
i'm kind of
unsatisfied by the ambition of our
current likewise it's almost like we got
settled with the social media and now
we're just
complacent and by the way social media
that's like first or second generation
these third generation social networks
and we are going to be built by
anthropologists
uh they're gonna be able to tweak very
specifically the culture
culture is a tool a tool set for
identifying beauty in the world
yeah every tea ceremony you watch
focuses on a different aspect of beauty
and a culture is a toolbox just like
technology
you know i hang out with a lot of these
um uh musician
and and kind of like spiritual types i
have a lot of fun uh dancing
uh with them freely right and um and
oftentimes this population comes
with it with a fear of technology almost
a resistance to it
um this this kind of fighting position
that they have with it like oh it's
trying to take over my life and control
me
and i try to help them understand that
it's just another tool
every tool can be used every instrument
uh can be used as a tool or a weapon
every single one uh and i believe virtue
helps us identify what are tools
and to hide the weapons because uh you
know between you and me i mean
uh to start with the genesis of a lot of
this i've destroyed the world in my mind
many times
full destruction and rebuilding
destruction and rebuilding
different tools different instruments
future ones past ones
and and you get in the end to the
conclusion
that it's just people
they're doing the best with what they
have
and if you free them uh from the slavery
of their
uh kind of human condition and and
they're
you know if you look at people uh
they're trying to do the right thing and
and
sometimes they do it for the the wrong
way but people are cute
in that sense they try to do the nice
thing they're trying to help their
mother they're trying to do these things
they love their families so it's a very
a beautiful thing when you truly look at
humans and and you start to
you start to um when covet hit i kind of
saw what was going to happen next the
simulation right imagine
uh imagine falling to your knees and
feeling the next
three 3.5 million people die in front
like you could feel that right you can
feel the holocaust
absorb it through your bones your bones
hurt
this is a different type of um kind of
not empathy but
there's a word for a collective pain a
collective consciousness a collective
emotion
so if you study history in order to
truly appreciate it
to appreciate the downfall of rome or
the death of carthage right um the
destruction of carthage by
by um uh scipio africanus
uh you you have to feel the pain
of a death of of an entire civilization
and the loss of
all of their miraculous culture which
has
beauty and and literature and poetry
that's all
lost and we will lose it again this is
this is a constant of history of
civilization
if you study it well enough uh and we
will all of this
all of this these questions that we can
now ask freely on the internet you have
a god-like power to ask and answer any
question in real time right now hey
google
what is the nature of the universe
that's doing something
and when we open that it will give a
pretty profound answer
about neuroscience or the cosmos
we know about the big bang you know we
we've come this far
and we're going to lose oh it's all
going to be wiped away
uh and usually happens during epic
cycles or epic periods it's a period
about 50 to 100 years
where there's such a radical rapid
evolution in human cognition and
consciousness
that uh that uh the forces of of of our
species kind of
the train of gas and breaks literally
rips it
apart it feels like that's about to
happen right now with fiat currency
dying
and the decentralized social fabric
emerging of
bitcoin and cryptocurrency ethereum and
ethereum
yeah of course yeah yeah absolutely yeah
because you want to be programmable
smart contracts and applications
this is that that's that's absolutely
right and then the
what do you think is going to happen you
know meaning where do you think it's
going to go
do you think these ancient systems that
are how much does a wire take three days
in a bank are you kidding me
what there's that's a lot of friction
that we're describing from here to here
is so much friction that's going to be
collapsed
and then i really liked your your
digital backpack
that you brought up i think that's
another really good way to visualize it
is that the profundity of capturing a
thought
like right now what happens to me
is that when something profound happens
between the guests and i
the best that i can do is sort of right
now be able to
create a tiny little note to myself
just right here about it and then aim to
do my best
to integrate that note into my digital
backpack
and that that's probably the best that i
can do right now
um and then the sort of next step
is to see if the ability to parse for
these
key insights like we had with the tax
and i think we should probably jump into
the
damage why don't we show them instead of
teasing them and then i just want to say
with the digital backpack we'll we'll go
right into synapse with this digital
backpack the most exciting thing for me
is that i already have these like 4
000 plus evernote files i already have
the 700 plus interviews all these
different kind of stuff and so what i
want to do is i want to be able to
have the my artificial intelligence
coach
i want the algorithms to basically
be on the continuous process of parsing
for these key insights like oh the tax
the creative tax on lack of foresight
right stuff like that
and then to throw that in the backpack
organize it in a way that helps me
be able to not only retrieve it later
but to combine it with other ideas do
synthesis and stuff like that so
yeah let's um let's jump into this demo
this is the so this is the synapse demo
do you want to give them a little
background on synapse yeah sure so
you know actually these ideas that you
capture these bunnies of beauty in real
time
um when you capture them you need to
uh they're they're useful just as
kind of just as a note and and and that
that problem has been solved but to add
a little bit of context
and and that's what synapse does it adds
uh layers of context uh uh
to these strips of thought so let's just
say
uh we have a thought right now some kind
of um uh idea comes out
uh in it is contextual data like for
example
the time that it was captured that's
relevant
if i had biometric data that's right it
would be your heartbeat
or your neuro signature which you would
be able to then train
i mean how else are you going to train
these headsets how
else so it's pretty obvious i mean these
things
and they become obvious once you once
you follow the threads
so far that the next thread begins
yes here i have it ready
all right so we have the as you guys can
see we have
synapse which tristan built it's
he's got it up right now that's his his
landing page in the background or his
website in the background at the links
in the bio below innovation
dash labs dot co and they find the link
in the bio below and he's got all this
awesome content there for uh the co
network and so let's um in on the right
side of the screen right now you're
you're observing his um phone background
which
are we are we getting um a signal i just
want to ensure that
that we're let me let me test it so
we'll test it quick
let's follow the thread okay let's just
give it a quick
looks like we might need a quick i'll
rest i'll get this a quick restart you
give
us a quick restart and we'll we'll so
that they that they can actually get the
all right so we're about to connect yeah
we're about to connect for you guys give
us a moment
we're using a mirroring software for
tristan's phone to be wireless with our
uh ndi scan converter that's then
bringing it into the stream
so we're we're connecting here boom
access start okay all right so
okay so we are
let's see i already changed it okay
there you should see so
now we're on okay
now we're on a tristan screen on there
on the right
this is a test note of inspiration
okay perfect so uh so let's say you've
captured a thought
um and so in this exact uh
it looks like the in the what we had as
we had it begin
to tristan basically he double-clicked
the uh lock button is that it has the
bixby button the
oh the bixby button and the samsung so
he double clicks the bixby button
it it begins to listen to what he's
saying and then he's saving that into
his note we'll go
we'll do this just we'll go through one
one more time because i want to actually
get the yeah yeah the experience yeah
get the get the exact experience
yeah there's a lot of software's running
here that's kind of the um
cloak just close let me close it there
you go that's a good idea yeah
we're we're actually running we're
running software
on tristan's phone and we're running
software on my computer and we're
running another there's like four layers
of software actually that are happening
so it's a big stack and and that is the
um that's actually the
uh oh that's an impeding of creativity
that's impeding but it's also the
opportunity
right now yeah it's also the opportunity
for people to truly
uh be able to build uh early versions
early versions of this technology and to
be able to capitalize on uh
innovation okay perfect it should be
capturing it now
so now that we've captured that let's
see if it gets it did it freeze a bit
again
come on come on get the last get the
last word get the last
word all yeah there we go so
uh so in addition to capturing the uh
the initial thought and and again uh so
we're talking about you
do you want to save oh you're do you
want to show that okay okay so the idea
is you're you're kind of walking and and
all of a sudden you
you have a moment and you just open your
phone it starts recording boom you
capture your thing
now you want to label it and i've
created these labels
uh i'm going to scroll them we'll see
when it adapts so you so you added
just the hashtag and then that's where
you're able to label it
yeah okay and now you're scrolling
through all of your different labels
yeah so these are labels that i've
created in the past so watch listen play
let's say you gave me a recommendation
for some anime or some
movie to watch it would immediately go
into this so what do we have here
early version so we're just going to
call this digital infrastructure that's
a course i'm creating right now
on uh on how to um how to do this anyway
click send boom gone now we continue our
conversation and uh
so you see how interesting how rapid
that was to capture insights store it
yeah and later on
again tonight or maybe next week uh and
i'll actually show you where this
all goes yeah yeah all right we're back
yeah so let me let me show you this so
okay
so this is opening uh a software called
dakota which
has uh which is going to profoundly
change the world
uh this is kind of like the birth of a
google or or just some
radical technology so i encourage
everyone to look into that i built this
suite
on top like the building blocks uh i
used on top of their system to host it
so uh and you could build a here let's
see if that
loads once yeah i'm gonna reload it yep
we're reloading right now let's try it
yeah
so did you did you you showed us synapse
there is coda different then
uh so so uh coda is uh kind of think of
it as like a wordpress
for um organizational apps essentially
right i call it a photoshop for
organization
and it's a radical new technology it
just got released it's pretty it's
pretty
new uh i would say notion would be a
competitor of theirs but uh
but let's be honest um um for the people
that build real data infrastructure
uh there's no substitute sorry so um
okay so now this is coda
yeah so this is kodo okay so we just
opened up my home page
uh i've designed this and again uh when
you open it on your
kind of you open up code on your own it
can be just a blank page so i've
engineered
a uh an algorithm for capturing
um um different things so you see here
the the first thing is a reverie cleaner
and that's where i clean
um reveries or or thoughts that i've
captured throughout the day
uh data diary that actually captures um
every thought i've made
per day and and uh per week so here's
i did a big data transfer so that's why
that's that many uh here's my workouts
and uh anyway so
there's a lot of data there uh let's go
back here
um mythologies this is a very
interesting category it actually
captures the my in your mythologies
interesting that's the
play there i like that the yeah the mai
and the mythology
so i have i have an aggression problem
like uh you know
i guess where i grew up or whatever i
had to survive and and uh
anyway um i i want to
lower my intensity but to maintain
my uh my presence and drive okay so you
need to regulate these things you need
to control them and and kind of
uh um don't let your just
emotions um affect
your environment because of the people
you love
so you need to develop ways to regulate
your
compassion your conflict your
contradictions uh your creativity
is it scrolling there yeah yeah your
energy your family your fears and this
captures
everything things that i'm grateful for
and i don't know maybe let's just jump
into that i guess
uh things that i'm grateful for um
these are just things that i've that
have did it jump in yeah it should have
jumped in yeah
looks like yeah i think it's gonna load
it's good give it a couple of seconds
yeah all right all right let's see if it
let's see if it does load here okay yeah
so and so in these are different under
each one is
or now do your hashtags go into coda as
well
or you you gotta you gotta describe your
digital backpack
sure sure so you would all make sense
but to us yeah so actually it's
it's it's a you know it's a combination
of tools right you have to jerry rig and
hack these things together so
the app that you saw initially that's
actually todoist popping up their quick
their quick action pop-up um and there i
i then um simulate a click on
on my screen uh on google gboard
uh which is my um keyboard it simulates
the click for the
uh recorder button and so it starts
recording and it was 350 milliseconds
after the app opens
okay so then it captures that then when
i put the categorization or the hashtag
of the item that i've selected um that
through zapier
wires it to coda oh interesting okay so
that's the collection
like the the buckets the the categories
that collects those inside of coda
uh zapier is my uh tool of choice for
wiring
rapid ideas and and got it the keyboard
is kind of the mechanism by which to
reduce
the uh the time between yes uh double
click
and actually having a my thought
registered inside of the database with
a functional um um category
or a master tag let's say master tag so
so it goes idea to
double click to the microphone for the
keyboard function enter in my
my voice translate to text then
after that is tag it and then
this part is synapse is the whole thing
synapse
that loads it into the synapse database
and the synapse is a
neurotechnology it's a it's a it's a
tool to explore your unconscious a
mirror
to reflect your unconscious okay so the
synapse part is that part that
i'm then categorizing yeah it's the
architecture
the architecture that then also works
with zap zapier that
then sends the to coda yes
yes okay so coda collects this data and
then manipulates it
code as your digital backpack yes this
is all your digital backpack
infrastructure but code is the actual
backpack itself that then yes
you go so to me the sort of way that i
kind of am doing this right now would be
that
i would do something like as i have that
profound thought i would probably
add that into one of my like evernote
files
but then it does seem like this is a lot
more
the speed i think is probably um
it might be somewhere around 5x it might
be five times faster to do it this way
is what it appears right now which is
which is very exciting that's a big deal
and
uh um so so what's even more interesting
is the actual post-processing
capabilities
uh which i would like to uh let me see
if we can mirror it yeah
we're starting the mirror again so i
gotta find okay i found it here mirror
pc
so um so now
to reflect this so so let me just let's
see if it pops up okay
so so here's uh and and these
architectures right they're
you they're they can be fairly
sophisticated i mean i've built too
close to about
15 of them to automate different aspects
of my
life so one would be a to-do list
tracker right build a focus module
and that's something in the hyper
productivity uh category right so you're
working on how to make things more
productive
these three buttons one of them is a uh
a dream capture actually maybe if we
click that it's a dream capture thing so
i wake up and i
i record a dream and i do an analysis so
you see how there's
pre-categorized things and if i choose a
category right so
uh you know i'm happy to show my let's
just say these are the
the so if it's a full lucid dream or or
or or um
you know our favorite uh let's say
section or zombie apocalypse
it creates a um it creates a
uh let's say a calculator right over
here so let's say
what was your lucidity in the dream so
that manipulates the sleep score
calculator
quality of sleep so essentially you're
training your mind to
uh to um get certain types of dreams uh
anyway that it's just research this is a
research thing
uh for lucid dreaming but
it's still nonetheless a uh almost a um
just a data tracking kind of scientific
tool for capturing uh
my uh the quantified self of
consciousness at its
yeah this is this is great actually i
did 50 push-ups earlier and this is my
daily workout thing so you could see
over here uh the blue one is a facial
it's funny it's face stretch i do
face stretch stretching's super
important
so uh so we just did some push-ups i'm
gonna click that 50 button
and that automatically gets rid of it
and shows me what i have left for the
day so this is my queue of workouts
and actually if you want to see deep
form that's my app that i built to track
my
uh my workouts and the average
completion and you could see my
i clearly don't do my burpees um
you know and you could go granularly
inside of any one of these and really
you you can become very intimate with
your data sets
uh as here are the thoughts that i
captured today
uh um some of these are uh
there's the creative tax for
incompetence yeah yeah you saw it over
there yeah
yeah let me show you fantasylab now this
is kind of a fascinating area
uh uh where uh i'm currently running
multiple
labs and it even shows what kind of lab
it is uh
so you know metamorphosis app would be
something where i'm training active
listening
uh i speak enough i talk a lot
and uh this year and next and next i
intend to
listen more carefully yeah you need to
track
your progress for that for that yeah the
whole planet does yeah that's a good one
uh there's empathy uh uh engine
there's different tools here uh um
coexistential institute that's kind of
like um
uh uh is essentially
uh it's a research uh
module for um existential risks
like climate change and other stuff and
that's where i'm putting the basis for
uh a fusion reactor
like we need to build a fusion reactor
in san diego we'll talk about that in
more detail later yeah we do
um so this tracks your thoughts on let's
say cognitive revolutions uh conflict
research i do a lot of that because
i understand where they're coming from
as a somebody with the with like
you know i have the dna for conquering
but if you really think about it and
this is talking to all the
conquerors out there you already own it
what are you conquering
you already own this this whole space
already belongs to
what are you trying to get more of what
are you hoarding
right so the hoarding behaviors it kind
of reduces that decision science is a
very powerful one
i want to take you into ego therapy
that's a very interesting one like
yeah yeah transforming
uh uh following ego all the way through
and actually turning negative ego into
positive ego to
there's a way to use ego as an
instrument as a tool
and uh i actually found that uh you know
the fuel that i used to use for
for my creativity and innovation has
been typically
uh sexual drive as well as aggressive
energy
fight kill or be killed right and
and that's worked and i i know a lot of
people that that works for that's fine
however over the last three to four
years i've been treated with so much
love yeah respect and and and compassion
i was just about to say that what if
love and compassion is
actually a better fuel that's actually
more efficient yeah
which is the mystic traditions actually
say that it is and
yeah i've gotten enough love over the
past four years to fuel
my creation of whatever stuff
for the rest of my life to to to
abundantly give it away
and i want to invest into people uh
and actually i mean this is maybe maybe
maybe the wrong strategy may be the
right one
i don't know but if the people that
deserve love at the least should
essentially get it the most
in order to wire them into the tapestry
of the collective
unconscious because they're barely
hanging on and
they want to contribute they just don't
know how and they
and they and they resist they fight back
they they want to be
noticed they want to help out
and they need to be given support on how
to do that i believe
which was like this potentially yeah
yeah
so let me show you some uh some cool
stuff so so
what's interesting here let's let's kind
of jump i want to jump into a cool one
uh let's see health monitor uh health
maturity dev kit that's a pretty cool
one uh maturity dev kit right maturity i
believe is the most important word of
the 21st century
uh because you can actually mature um um
radically mature if you if you focus on
maturing in certain areas and these are
buckets or wisdom playbooks that have
synthesized out of the
thousands of thousands of notes that you
know these are all
notes that are then compiled into
these uh um categories
and that's where you recognize your
fallibility your
your your humanity you rediscover it
and and you surrender to
to your weakness and and just to your
love like like you start loving again
you start loving humanity
um anyway the point is uh the people
that uh you know i have this question um
that i often ask people should we
survive as a species should we make it
should we should we continue or should
we be annihilated by ai by asteroids by
climate uh and i will and i'm going to
ask
publicly right now kind of on on the
scene uh sh
should should we make it uh should we go
extinct or not
yes or no
do we deserve it for what we've done to
each other
and to ourselves
i answer right now i want to live
we want to live no hesitation no no
start experiment for me no hesitation
there's not a second of hesitation
uh of course i want to live and uh
and gently push away all the people that
uh struggle to find
that answer because they don't they
haven't matured enough to appreciate
the the profound beauty of life they
need to be guided
they need to be loved in order to
recognize
their place in the universe their
ecosystemic role
in the society an open source society
where people contribute and add
um essentially
elect themselves to fix the republic
i don't need to wait until somebody
hires me to fix my road or to build
a school or to build a fusion reactor in
order to
convert seawater into you know tritium
and deuterium and then and then power
the city
vertical farms i'm not waiting for any
government
to do in fact if they get in my way you
know there's consequences to that
uh i'm not waiting for anybody and i
don't think anybody else should either
you want a society you build it
you compose it you are the composer of
this reality and and
uh and and bring me the person that that
tells you
otherwise you know
it's really interesting to me
when you begin
showcasing the way that you've decided
to
architect synapse and
coda so is coda is also a product of
uh uh this is actually a really
interesting point um
um uh co-network
uh connect physically collaborate
digitally right the computational
renaissance
uh i started that uh uh after the
machine learning society and that's been
uh
kind of a a network that i've hybridized
with right you can you can find these
parasitic networks but but positive pair
you know parasitism can be uh uh it can
be beneficial
with the appropriate organism so the
this social network has
uh attached to the anthropo an
anthropologist
uh and we and we observe and explore the
world together we
we help each other grow and i believe
this will be a common theme where
i believe maybe simulation might be your
hybrid network okay these things
hybridize with us and then they
they they uh uh they feed off of our
psychic energy and we feed them with
data
right so this is very interesting coda
is a it's a beautiful
software and it's actually out of
silicon valley and i've uh
i i use it in order to architect these
uh databases
so i'm an artist on top of this coda
infrastructure
okay got it got it so
is it something like
you figured out a way that
you think right now is most efficient
given what exists to do the digital
backpack because to me
given the amount of
craziness that you just walked us
through
that digital backpack is in a sense is
kind of
unpacked at your cognitive architectural
level
and it would kind of be interesting to
see
how if given
the tools like with my
like 4 000 evernotes and these 700
interviews and this type of stuff
if there was a way to work on the
process
of like hyper
efficiency and hyper
hierarchical sort of north star
prioritization of content
so that this sort of
constant process of
always having the ai coach being showing
in the digital backpack
what the primary
[Music]
star point is in longevity and
enlightenment
in the
north star execution so one of the
things that
sort of seems to me to be happening as a
sense is that there is like a
there's like a version of this that's
working really well for you but that
there's
nobody else is it available for people
to other people to come in
they can build it if they want to and i
intend
to um uh distribute it as soon as it's
ready for
uh you know the mass now this is
existential technology meaning it's so
powerful that
every writer knows this whatever you
write down starts to happen
it starts to reveal itself into the
world so
uh i want to make sure to bring with
this
a ethical um
just a a set of every set of tools again
can be a a tool or a weapon and
uh the people that want to use this as a
toolbox for their
uh uh creativity i support
and i will restrict proactively
uh by any means necessary this
technology from people that
are going to misuse it uh and i think
this is a general
you know this is only one document but
and i believe this architecture
synapse will be used more for trauma
editing
for for uh uh collecting
ev every thought you collect it
typically actually if you um
if you look at them as a wave rather
than a particle
every thought is a particle but when you
look at it as a wave emotions are waves
they're not
they're not a single point it's a
distributed kind of thing
uh you often reveal uh you're trying to
describe the same thing over a period of
you know weeks
uh from different angles you're kind of
collecting angular
data about it and when you see it in in
perspective in in
a line you go oh so this sentence has a
piece of this
this sentence has a piece of that and
you you consolidate
those topics those points those
individual reveries
into a wisdom playbook
and all of a sudden now you have a
concrete
structure of a synthesis of information
that you can now uh leverage for your
to-do list and and i kind of described
this technology actually as a
so i ride a motorcycle uh a victory
hammer
2017 and uh beautiful bike
i love that that feeling uh
it's it's about as intense as i am 1750
cc's
but when i when i use this technology on
my desktop computer at home in san diego
i feel like i've been on my bike like
i've been in a jet fighter like strapped
in with like
you know g-force on me it really feels
that intense and
and uh what i'm doing when i'm flying
around that thing is i'm sniping out to
do's
yep so there's moments when i run out of
things to do
you know that's a very weird feeling
when you're like i actually have nothing
to do because
i've done all of my to-do's i need to
now go to a drawing board and figure out
what i need to do next
you know it's a very interesting feeling
i would like to actually
i open this up over here maybe they can
see it so uh
number one uh and i think one of the
interesting things here is actually that
um
each thought each uh each reverie i call
them
uh can be distributed and these are the
ones that i've found i'm sure there's
more but these are
uh building blocks lego bricks which
compose
the uh so so for categories for example
uh these are
uh you know i've found and these are
experimental but um
this could be a goal or it could be
something that i'm grateful for or
something that's hilarious something
that's
love related or metaphor now you get to
categorize uh
you know projects these are the projects
that i'm currently running
uh so you can actually label things
briefly just also show what's at the top
there which is the actual
sort of take care of your mom they are
more fragile than you think
so nice so nice yeah yeah yeah yeah like
if you're
now what are you doing with this two
sentences
well number one um just uh
it's a profound thought so this is one
of the things that you
double click in you fill into the
digital backpack
and then what do you do with these two
sentences in order to be able to
make it enhance your
north star creativity yes yeah my my mom
is an angel
um like like a real angel yeah uh which
makes my father the a demon uh you know
but that's a different time different
story different place
uh but um the uh
this idea this thing i i captured and
and uh
it's just a reminder to to take care of
my mom to to to
uh to you know send her flowers everyone
smile to to
actually support her right our moms if
you really think about it they're
currently experiencing this digital
revolution
on facebook they can't they don't know
that the system this machine
is is targeting them they're unaware and
and they could be let down
cognitive alleys that they're not
equipped
to deal with their time can be
taken from them with games and
little uh dings and bings and
notifications
as an as a designer of social networks i
i'm
very proactive in reducing all the
notifications that i get throughout the
day
and i'm a professional at this so again
every single one of them
snaps you out of your momentum focus
when you're focusing when you're really
trying to get to the bottom of an idea
uh and interpret it uh sometimes a ding
or a bing somewhere can
really bring you out of that momentum
amen yeah cal newport deep work
it's really important yeah so you need
to you need to be hyper vigilant
in maintaining your focus and your
attention
you need to control that and with that
um
that all of a sudden enables new
capabilities the moment you have your
focus and your attention
all of a sudden you get to attend to or
focus on
for some family for some yourself if you
need that
that uh time to reflect upon yourself
and for some on others on your community
and that's where i'm at right now
to to give back all of the
love and compassion that i've received
over these last years
you collect psychic energy
you build you create in the sounds of
your
of you you know and then you reveal and
you release and you give back
that is the it's like contract it's like
sponge theory
in high level perception
yeah it's super super duper aligned
it's a very sponge theory can you
explain this a little bit
it's just interesting that that you
describe that
one because it's
yeah it's uh
yeah it's like when you absorb
the as like a sponge you absorb
the peaks of the fitness landscape in
different disciplines if you're trying
to systematize genius
and then you add your unique soul angle
to that
and wring it out as a creative
contribution that's why it's sponge
[Music]
smoke and then ring it i like that yeah
so okay yeah yeah the porous absorption
of that kind of the the surface area
yeah you let
like because the sponge you know it can
have it was a ridiculous fact that i
uh like the lungs or something have 70
uh 70
meters of of of surface area while your
skin only has seven
like something ridiculous like that and
if you really think about the this is
because of the alveoli
yeah yeah so it was it was that fact
profoundly
uh affected me and then i recorded it
into the profound category to remind me
um to look up and and to you know look
at the divine uh
that's one and then another one is those
yeah those bronchi and the
alveoli in the lungs and then there's
also the the villi
the villus in the gastrointestinal tract
there's all these little tiny
hairs and so it's again one of those
surface area ones and so there's a lot
of absorption that happens there like
with these
ideas and and concepts something that i
thought was
really interesting as you're like
walking us through
synapse was that i like
i like how it's really it's kind of like
in essence
it's a it's mostly it's a reflection of
your
consciousness your creativity it's your
architecting of what you think is going
to be the most
optimal sort of tech stack for your
digital backpack
and right now you know i know that i'm
using a digital backpack and i know
other people are using these digital
backpacks
not everybody is but then a lot of
people are realizing that their digital
backpacks can use these improvements
like we're talking about
on the conversation as well and that
it's a little bit
difficult right now for the creatives
that want to up
augment their digital backpacks to
figure out how to do so because the
sort of systematized processes that
enable us to do so are a little bit
in a sense limited right now and so it's
cool seeing
yours because yours is it's really it's
like it's your
own unique reflection of what you think
is kind of the next gen step here
and i i'm what's really interesting to
me is i'm trying to think about what
mine would look like and what the other
creatives that are listening that have
these digital
backpacks how they would sort of also
try and organize theirs
and systematize theirs and make it so
that they can cut those
like we were saying all these you know
steps in the middle of the process away
so they can systematize the creativity
so i'm thinking about it like that
so it sounds like we have we have again
we have the synapse process we have the
coda infrastructure
and then we have um
this is all in your digital backpack
tristan
tyler blake's yeah in individual digital
backpack for now
because the tool itself like you
described is the double edge so you want
to make sure that it's going to the
creatives that you trust ethically and
morally this type of stuff yeah i want
to accelerate specific people high
performers people that i trust and like
so uh my friends out there and community
members
uh you're welcome to reach out and uh
and uh you know we'll we'll get you
hooked up
and just people that i'm uh impressed by
so i want to give it to the best first
and then i'll i'll let them make the
decision on who should uh
share and the uh compliments of of excel
of this kind of
cognitive acceleration so
are you gonna make like an sdk for them
or what how what are you going to do
we'll see that that that's a a a an
entire journey
i'm actually i intend to build a a year
ago
a year ago when we interviewed tristan
he was kind of more in the nascent
stages of this
in the last year he's really built this
out a lot more
and so you did you say you wanted to
make this a course
yeah i'm going to build a a course on
digital infrastructure for inventors
yeah okay cool so that's going to be a
highly specialized course like a think
of it as a digital
uh like like a a fitted custom suit for
inventors like a digital
you know outfit i i see these things as
really custom fitted data
infrastructures
for your body specifically that's right
it's it's very much so like the
fingerprint the digital backpack's like
a fingerprint
and so i see so the course would enable
the
the hyper creative to
figure out how to make the fingerprint
digital backpack for themselves
okay and then they'll undergo that
process and it's kind of like an
invite-only tree branching style thing
where
um they'll be ethically morally people
will be um
they'll be held to responsible for the
people they invite and stuff like that
yeah
and then so then this is all going to be
branded as something like synapse or
it will be called digital backpacks so
synapse is the
uh psychological uh uh um
app that kind of ambiently collects your
inspirations and and the snapshots of
your emotions right and eventually you
see
you see down there uh yeah okay all
right we're up
so so you see down there there's
actually uh so a couple of more
concepts like neurotilts are are
fascinating different um
uh um archetypes that you engineer for
specific situations so these are fun
experimental
uh psychological kind of uh things um
but down here uh so number one when i'm
when i'm preparing for a podcast or
or whatever um i can actually um
drop down that media button and i'm i'm
kind of writing
dozens of articles and uh creating
dozens of videos at the same time and
when they're ready
when they're mature they kind of they
show themselves as having the
appropriate
um um you know data collected and i
simply compile it i
add the um the the uh
syntax to it and all of a sudden it's
kind of a
written article that i've pre-written
just by walking around and and one of
the things
uh i've been trying to build a social
network for writers since i was 19 that
was my first product i think that i ever
literati.com was a long time ago uh and
uh ever since then as a writer myself
i've always wanted to
give writers tools to create these
three-dimensional writing schemas like
character analysis like every reference
of the character
i want to see that and then in the
following sentences you know it's a
data-driven
approach to it well um uh what's
interesting here is
you actually uh are able to write and
and by chapters you can organize so you
could compose
a book ambiently nobody
i don't make very few writers sit down
and write the book i love this so okay
so let me see if i can hit this ball
back again so
the idea is that synapse is what enables
the
ambient collection of the
ideas in the ocean to more
rapidly uh be integrated into the
digital backpack
and so okay so we have that component to
it and then we have again the the coda
infrastructure we have the
um the the overarching idea of a digital
backpack so is there a brand for
all of this yet that's or or is that
synapse or co-network
is the um or co-innovation labs
that's kind of the overall um uh
inventor sort of studio okay so co
so code networks innovation labs is the
uh highest level umbrella of what is
building
out the uh the synapse and the coda
connection and the digital backpacks and
then to properly
okay now i know i'm following so machine
learning society is the community
mls site is the community arm and that's
really cool because you can actually
find out who in new york and san diego
and all these different places is
actually doing what work in biotech or
in
or in blockchains and ethereum
applications d-apps
and i host many events using this
actually i mean just for
event organizers and community
organizers uh again if
you really think every time you host an
event you take uh you do the same steps
over and over and and
you give it a name you have a picture
and once you really do this enough time
you recognize that uh three hours of
work with
a system like this and simply tagging
the people you want to invite for
speaker sponsor blah blah blah and you
wire out
uh emails uh so now you could plug this
in
to um to gmail you could plug it in to
uh different apps for text messaging uh
slack for team management i'm very
interested in high performance teams
so um some most of my research actually
goes into
uh maybe maybe i could pull this up as a
fancy high performance team research so
i really wanna
uh let's say the mission is to either
snipe out uh
you know an asteroid heading our way and
we have five days to do it and we need
five of the world's top experts
how would you def decide on who are the
people that are going to have the best
aim
yeah this is right exactly legitimate
question this is very important there's
a lot of these sort of
critical questions like that mirrors and
satellites
may i may i for a moment because i think
i think one of the things that
um people like especially like you
may be extremely um uh
you might be underestimating a bit or
maybe in this case it'd be
over i think yeah i think it's over yeah
you're i think you're
overestimating the
ability of people to understand your own
cognitive schema
oh yeah maybe okay so i think that's why
i have to do this because
because i'm having a lot of i've known
you for a couple years
and i don't even i don't even fully
follow
a lot of your schema and and i've known
you a couple years and so
now you're you know you're on the
program and you're trying to share your
schema
and we need in a sense we just we just
need a a small little
um architectural map
yeah exactly and so and so what i'll do
is i'll try and
sort of do this and then you can tell me
where where things are
on or off and stuff so and then i would
love to show them stem
notebook which was a totally totally
different but that's the integration but
that's
the stem notebook is still within
co-network right yes it's
co-networks innovation labs right yes
and and
is it correct to say that uh stem
notebook within code network innovation
labs
is it's um it's it's not it's connected
to
synapse and digital backpacks and stuff
like that but it's it's its own sort of
branch of that
okay so all right let's let's let me let
me draw this
okay
okay so the top umbrella term is the
is the co network and then you have you
know these are the
you have the innovation labs
and then now you have the this is the
sort of uh
you know this is the digital backpack
and we're actually let me use a
i just want to use another color to sort
of help with this see the step that
you're doing actually um
that's one of the interesting things
that once you start building your
custom fitted suit your right your data
uh
infrastructure uh you start to have to
catalog things and
use taxonomy uh and build an ontology
your own specific one yeah and once you
have to do that that force that's a
forcing function
for you to now organize and catalog
things
and you start recognizing that oh wait a
minute this is connected to there or
this
piece of wisdom is relevant in multiple
projects you don't have to rewrite it
again
you know you've already done the
analysis on this the calculus
and now you simply need to uh let it uh
uh um be useful in multiple projects so
so that's kind of the also the symmetry
of
of the system there's there's a lot of
beauty in in the way that it's composed
as well in that perspective
yep so
all right so this uses those so okay if
i have this right
you the co network innovation labs is
the umbrella and then
within it you have the architecture
co-innovation labs
is the is the top co-innovation labs
yeah
and the network is like more like the ml
society co-network is a social
network that i built for computational
scientists
yes and so co-innovation labs is the
umbrella for these two specific things
so so we have so we have the we have the
yeah so we have the co-network and we
have the
ml society and then
we have the so we have the co network we
have demo site and then we have
co-innovation
labs which is this and under
co-innovation labs we have the digital
backpack idea which is using synapse and
coda
and then we have the stem notebook idea
which we're going to unpack here in a
moment is this correct
yeah yeah yeah yeah okay okay and by the
way these are pretty fluid things
they're very fluid things it's not to
try and box things it's just more to
create
an architecture for people to actually
get sure what we're talking about
because we've been talking about a lot
of different
uh ideas and terms and so i just
it's it's a lot different you as a guest
on the program
are you're just a lot different than a
lot of other guests and
you also speak about it in a way that
is assuming that other people are really
following the way that you're explaining
your architectures and whatnot
and so my role is to just try and help
put it in some sort of a way
that visualizes for people to get it at
a deeper yeah yeah sure yeah yeah so and
i really like this helpful
as an ecosystem role by the way your
your ability to
um to take it synthesize what i say and
introduce it to a population i've become
so appreciative of this
role in society because yeah
you recognize that some people will hear
what you have to say and others
need another voice to make it clear and
and
amen you got it and that's beautiful
that's what that's
that's been happening since the
beginning of time there have been so
many geniuses that have
kind of had a um a struggle with
communicating what's at the peak of
their
uh conceptual schema and they need some
sort of
an assistant in the process and i i am
that for so many different people that
a translator translator eli five art
synthesis distillation this type of
stuff i like that you are definitely a
translator of
of of uh complex ideas and you simplify
them a lot and that's uh
yeah uh the beauty of simplifying ideas
and that's em
equals mc square right that's a that's a
that's a lot of stuff
synthesized into a useful practical um
um tool that any day people can use and
that's why
uh that's why a schmuck can throw a
nuclear warhead at somebody else
uh which by the way needs to be resolved
uh you know that whole thing
uh i'm sorry but people don't that don't
understand physics
shouldn't have power over nuclear
technologies that's a
that's a no-go right now uh um you know
what i mean
yeah we gotta be careful with the
democratization of the powerful
power of power power period power must
only be held by those that have uh
earned with their wisdom and uh
especially those kinds of
you mentioned earlier a metaphysical
point about whether we should hit our
godhead or not and i
i didn't hit the ball back but i i'm
generally
uh in a pretty good understanding of
darwinian metaphysics and i
i do think that that applies and i think
it would be a good idea for us on a
universal level to take this seriously
and to reach our godhead and so
that would be my sort of quick two sense
about that but
i think we should definitely show did we
do enough on before we do stem notebook
we did enough i think covering
okay let's go to stem yeah yeah i think
i think that
first of all what i've found is uh
depending on your data metabolism your
ability to
uh absorb information uh
some people just get full like a cup
like imagine pouring water into a cup
and it just starts to overflow there
actually tristan's been using this
really good word um since he came
and i hadn't i hadn't sort of put these
concepts together yet but
the same way that we have a metabolism
our ability to
to physiologically power our biological
organism it's the same way that
tristan's describing
data metabolism and i think it's a
really important analogy because
before we started we were talking about
the different
resolutions of perception and in many
ways this is extremely deeply aligned
with high level perception and so
it's important that if you are
potentially living in more of a
uni-dimensional
sort of analysis or maybe you're in the
center of the bell curve and you're
reasoning with a couple of these pieces
take your time with the style of content
go back
and look up words that you don't know
really try and
immerse yourself at a deeper level into
upgrading your perception to seeing in
like 1080p and 4k and above and that
kind of stuff and so
eventually will i appreciate data
metabolism it's a good one it's uh you
can tell when you're talking to somebody
that is
um but you can tell by just by the way
that they
um hit the tennis ball back in the game
of tennis so if they
if they do a good job at hitting the
tennis ball back they've been they've
they were able to metabolize and add
their own creativity
but if they do a really bad job um or
just completely ignore
the profundity of the things you were
saying then you know that you're
speaking at a different level of
resolution
yeah and we're here to invest in those
people to see clearly yeah like we're
here to invest into you
i want you to think about how
when this uh autonomous vehicle company
that you're thinking about
you want to you know put a library maybe
in your autonomous vehicle you want to
put a chess set in yours and market it
to people that
that do that so it's a very interesting
opportunity i want to integrate
uh the collective intelligence of the
community and
nobody should be left behind on you know
unless they've uh it's the role of
portals
yeah there's there's absolutely no
reason why people should be
left behind and they won't be this is
chapter four portals and high level
perception and
you absolutely have to you know uh the
the bell curve is moving at an
evolutionary pace
in the oroboro cyclical shape as we
explore infinity as consciousness and in
this case
everybody is slowly moving away from
violence tyranny
slavery corruption this type of thing up
over time to the genius visionary level
and so portalists are people like what
we're describing that then
go and perform these incredible feats of
shooting some sort of a portal
into the bell curve that enables people
to upgrade their perception so
this is absolutely critical um aspect
is bringing everyone along with the
journey and focusing on that process so
let's do some notebooks yeah all right
and i often find that that when you uh
when you
uh when you look for others to destroy
you're typically uh
uh destroying with the parts of yourself
that you hate in them
well every time so notice your hate uh
and you can run out of hate
uh you can run out of these uh things uh
and and when you do
you'll recognize that you're destroying
the reflection of yourself
leave your mental disease out
of the society like like hold it on your
own do not introduce it into the
ecosystem we have no room for that
especially during this time of a great
uh stress
like keep it to yourself um you know or
work on it at the very least and there's
tools
tools for that for trauma repair do not
uh
bring it to the public square yep yeah
so
let's unpack stem notebook so this is on
when you hit the site um
when you hit in innovation
dash labs dot co on the link in the bio
below
on the left you'll see stem notebook and
you can click that or there's another
link for stem notebook in the bio below
as well
and then that'll take you here and so
what are we dealing with with stem
notebook tristan
yeah so um you know i i read a lot of
books and i
i've been watching a lot of lectures
particularly these last few months
uh on neuroscience and music and
biology i finally started to to tap to
touch
to understand uh you know biochemistry
like it's been a
a long process that i've been afraid of
it to a certain extent it's so
complicated
yeah so many moving parts and pieces and
for a person that's uh
that doesn't have a you know uh the
ability to invest into a university and
a family to hold them there
uh over a period of four years right and
they have to take debt on
uh aka slavery so uh this is a tool a
vehicle for people to
be able to um touch um
science to absorb it to interact with it
without uh
without having to invest the um all of
this
research of years and years of just
compiling relationships between
different phenomena
this synthesizes it for you and and i'll
show you how that happens
in practice of course you you need to do
the work and you need to watch the
lectures but but when you're ready to um
to take when you take your notes and as
a child
i never took notes in school i have very
bad grades from high school
uh and and from from college very very
bad
uh and that's because i was uh not empow
i
i guess i couldn't even read my own
handwriting or something like that so
one thing that i want to mention is that
these tools are built out of uh
um like out of out of necessity
i wouldn't survive if i didn't have the
ability to organize myself
because of my lack of natural
um organization yeah i had to build
mechanisms
to help me track you know myself
uh in order to improve myself otherwise
if i was left to just
do it based on memory i would i would
vanish so that's a very interesting
point that this is
out of desperation literally and and
that's where a lot of people can come to
it
in the sense of he'll oh this will hold
you up you won't forget it as soon as
you stop
yeah this holds it in a digit
like like a ram you know like like
imagine an external database
a memory bank and i study memory pretty
pretty uh substantially
um so this is kind of like a memory bank
that holds the knowledge that you've
acquired for you
and when you need it when you go back
it's always there
i appreciate your story about the
forcing function i think that's a really
interesting
um story a lot of people that are
neuro-diverse are experiencing forcing
functions of needing to
really embody their like genius level
mutant mutations and that
will hopefully be a forcing function to
create the architectures that enable
more people to
express themselves creatively given how
the
vast majority of the evolutionary pacers
stamping out gingerbread cookies
so is it true then to say something like
a a stem note the stem notebook would be
something like the
like the when you talk about a subject
like biochemistry and the complexity of
it
it's it's basically trying to connect
the dots in the field of biochemistry
and give that in a relatable way to the
one that's interested in pursuing it
yeah yeah and so let's see how that
looks like in practice so so number one
if you if you scroll over here
uh scroll down so you see those buttons
they're not active for you because
you're not the owner of the dock but
eventually
um i'll i'll allow people to fork from
here to just
fork and start from this point okay and
then to be able to
um um uh develop their own journeys so
these are the current uh books lectures
podcasts that i'm
currently uh um covering okay click into
one
oh yeah i try to click into one let's
see what happens yeah try to click into
that
uh so can you open that that box on the
left try to try that box all the way on
the left right then
a little bit to the right of this box a
little to the that one
try to open it let's see okay so here
with the data that you see
um it catalogs uh the um
uh the actual um course the lecture so
it's
and if you don't see it but there's a
drop down for books for everything so
i've cataloged this
um by domain if you scroll down this
covers so i've already covered this many
times in the past
but uh so i'm re-listening to it again
and this is for every book
uh um in the in the database so if you
click on the top
all the way in the top yes right there
yeah click on that that will show you
actually sorry that's the data master go
on the left side yep
and click on books lectures film yep
right there
okay so that view that you were seeing
before
is now being represented in a totally
different way and that's actually the
beauty of this technology lets you
see things as graphs charts tiles
and and you get insight into missing
data just by um
visualizing it in a different way yeah
that's a process
definitely it's a very powerful process
we were talking about that a lot when
just like earlier in this episode where
we were talking about the visualization
of what's in the data silos and
leveraging that so is would you say that
this
is a a
a tailored or personalized like do i
when i land on stem notebook am i
um am i like selecting my interests of
where i want to pursue and then
you kind of say that these are some
really good syntheses of
the subjects that you want to pursue in
like relatable videos or relatable books
or relatable
podcasts um so watch these and then
you'll get a little score on how you
test or something yeah yeah precisely
yeah so
so over here you're seeing uh books that
are in the ai and computational sciences
category
the black ones i've read the white ones
are next so i know exactly what i don't
know or what i need to
read and if you scroll down this is a
pretty uh uh
uh you know there's a lot of books
some of them are ranked this is my
personal ranking
um but these are the things that i've
covered so far uh
by category up there and if you scroll
up you could click uh uh so this
if you scroll all the way up oh okay
click on lectures
so this will be a consolidated list of
lectures in every category
and and this is kind of the um the
methodology
right to actually um organize things and
and and create groups and i could do
this in any way that i want
yeah this is super interesting so in a
sense it's like
let me see if i can hit this ball back
so it's it's
maybe it's it's uh it's something along
the lines of this
like currently we're
maybe um looking at
specific fields of interest that were
that we really enjoy and that we're
really excited about and what's
happening is we basically
maybe will will read a book or we'll
watch a youtube
podcast or a lecture on a specific
subject and then what happens is that
basically disappears from our vis
data visualization stream and we no
longer ever
yeah get the opportunity to kind of look
at you know who we were how we got here
the data visualization process
we can go back and see it so in this
actual notes from the book
and yeah directly like the quotes from
the book
rather than for me like taking my like i
noticed here
just uh just searching start let me let
me start here because i think i can
maybe try and make this relatable for me
and others
um okay so here for
under like cognitive sciences and
psychology you have books that are very
common for those that are quite awake i
would say um
behaved by robert sapolsky homo deus by
evolnor harari stealing fire
by stephen kotler why we sleep by
matthew walker thinking fast and slow by
uh daniel kahneman and uh emma sversky
and
i think what we're sort of seeing here
is that
rather than sort of um
getting through these books and sort of
just having them
separately in your library
shelves and then or digitally on your
kindle or whatever
and then having like my notes for
example on homo deus or why we sleep by
matt walker
my notes are in evernote then and then
if i want to ever access those i need to
go there and access them there
i see you have these little bars at the
top that show maybe
progress or proficiency maybe is another
way
like even if you've read you know why we
sleep you read it three years ago
how much do you really remember from why
we sleep and so maybe there's
you know for me the way that i would go
back right now is i would go to my note
in evernote why we sleep and i would
look for
because i do this process of exegesis
where i basically highlight out or star
use emojis and colors and buildings and
all this type of work
to sort of draw out the salient points
and i would have to go and review that
for like 5-10 minutes
before i would maybe talk to matt about
his
work and so or if i want to revisit it
because someone else triggered me to
revisit it
so sort of this is the process of being
able to catalog
your not only what you did in terms of
books lectures podcasts where you're
sort of heading you this is the
beginnings of that sort of ai coach that
helps
along the way of oh we're noticing that
you want to get into learning how to do
uh dapps on ethereum in order for you to
do so you have to
you know watch these four talks that
vitalik gives
this type of thing and you have to go
through the process of actually doing
one of the
um programming uh yourself in ethereum
and
so i really like that a lot i think that
it's a very important and helpful
um visualization so the stem notebook is
tailored
individually yeah uh yeah so so this is
a
general like these are just my business
actually click on uh that retina
dashboard okay and i see there's a sign
in button in the top right corner
yeah that's dakota oh that's the code
yeah and so this is built on top this is
built on top of coda and then is there
a is there
a existing for the co network at least
can they
join stem notebook or is it right now
it's an observing mode
i'm still building it for myself i'm
still taking notes on books i just need
it for myself
and they observe you you're you're
you're
you're
you're
you're
you're
you're
you're
you're
you're
you're you're
you're
you're
you're
you're you're
you're
you're
you're
you're you're
you're
you're
you're
you're you're you you i want people to see
what's possible
experiment on their own then i'll give
them the the actual course the tool set
and then let them so same thing with the
digital backpack we were talking about
earlier
yeah and there's a couple of other apps
that i see i see so right in the
dashboard yeah so yeah so
this button if you were to click it it
would immediately take you to a new note
in that book so that it's a kind of a
rapid entry book so
it's very cool here shows you like a
graph of uh
my current knowledge so this is what oh
what percentage you're complete in these
different fields so you
you wrote these different titles of
fields that you want to pursue as your
interest
and then you've added the little like uh
the little widgets of the different
fields and maybe you've added like 26
widgets and then if you've only done
uh 13 of them it would say 50 precisely
yes yes
so i'm tracking my progress just to make
sure that uh um it's a forcing function
for me to continue reading and plus
when i finish this i know what i need to
do next like i like all those books that
you saw that are white
they're gonna one by one kind of fall
into the black zone yeah
i'm covering knowledge that i need and
i'm prioritizing the knowledge that i
need to know
yeah yeah uh based on and you're doing
it in a way that is
really systematized and organized
towards that north star you're kind of
acting as your own ai coach right now
like um i i kind of i'm getting your
analogy more in terms of you
kind of flying in that like jet and like
tackling the
to do's because you've kind of made a
process for yourself that enables you to
do that whereas
so many of us are still kind of in like
maybe like
i have the google calendar and the
evernote and there's like all these
other sort of places that are storing
these
items yes yeah yeah your your cost of
jumping between these apps you forget
what you were doing
like like you you needed to post
something on facebook you forget why
you're there and you're all of a sudden
scrolling something like that i built a
dark geometry media toolkit that as soon
as i post like i can
i can record something right now uh post
it there and it will wire it out to all
of my social networks at once through
zapier
yeah stuff like that yeah i don't i just
don't have time to post it on each one
you know so
um and these tools that's a big waste of
time right now i agree and there's some
software that's doing that but it's not
as
quick as what you're explaining yeah so
what's what's this now uh this is uh
just a distribution of my knowledge
uh uh in terms of what i've covered so
this is all the books that i've
completed or lectures or whatever by
if you scroll down you'll see like which
uh what are the categories oh there they
are yeah so
so this is kind of for me to see oh wow
i have a lot of um
work in that and now i'm catching up on
you know my my bio my biology or
whatever
and if you scroll even lower so this is
this is this is this is a data
visualization tool for your cognitive
schema
based on how many books lectures
podcasts
that you've analyzed in the space of
that specific domain
and that's a really useful visualization
tool
um i really like what you're doing here
and then this is another visualization
yeah just another way to see
actually this visualizes uh how many
concepts
i have in my inquiry map and we're gonna
jump you're gonna be able to click on
this in a sec
so uh these concepts are i'm developing
like uh
you know uh there are concepts in
biology in biology or physics
uh that uh require a definition or notes
so if you click on inquiry map you'll
actually get to see this is cool
uh what happens there so so let's just
zoom out a little okay so now this is
actually the bread and butter of this
whole thing
graphic this is the bread and butter so
uh click on artificial intelligence
let's say
okay the inquiry map okay
so this is where those 400 concepts that
were in the last graph
are so now if i go and i
learn from books podcasts lectures and i
take in these 400 ai concepts
right now my best way of doing this is i
have these i have evernotes that are
specifically titled
um like concepts like my core concepts
and so then in those core concepts what
i have is i have the
i have it chunked up by like biotech or
neurotech or ai or blockchain
and then it's and then it's i'm doing
exegesis again where i'm bolding
like the word itself and then i'm i have
the
the definition as synthesized as i've
done it
and so in this case this looks so much
higher level
because again here's all the different
categories on the left
and then from here then you click into
ai
and you go boom until the first like ai
bioinformatics bring computer interfaces
etc
so click on one of them like click on
another one just listen to cybernetics
okay
so these are the main concepts in
cybernetics
that i've found and
oh this is way better yeah this is way
better and you open open one of them
like
this is way better it's way faster it's
way more
um properly organized related
and for example like yeah it's just for
me when i
do i like will literally look for the
word cybernetics in my notes and then
i'll find where i put the
main definition but my my process of
synthesis is very much like yours
but you've put it into coda which is way
more efficient than evernote for what
we're trying to both
do so you're teaching me a lot about the
structure of the data to make it a lot
more visual
this is a much better tool for hyper
creatives and hyper conceptual people
to be able to actualize um
their fullest potential through data
visualization in a way that's just more
native and more
um it's it's it's a lot better hey coda
if you're listening
uh um somebody needs to build out your
vr
data visualizations like
call me i can see i can see what it's
going to look like
and how to manipulate data in in
multiple dimensions in a vr headset
and this will take on a life of its own
in another way an experiential data a
knowledge graph like
yeah you'll be able to actually interact
and impact your
this is step this is step two you know
maybe if step
one is kind of what we're talking about
with like where wikipedia
is nowhere near this caliber of in my
opinion
the hyperlinks there are a lot less
structured like this and it's not as
actually fruitful
and in my notes where i try and do it
that's another small step
up this is a bigger step up but it's
still a step
behind what we were just mentioning when
you said that there's this beautiful
data visualized knowledge graph that you
get to interact with
in like an ar or vr space that's the
next step in the neural link
and stuff is like the step above that so
but you have to get there we have to get
there and this
is the s this is the next step towards
that and then
like you just plugged with coda the next
step is to do this
in the vr space and make it visual it's
inevitable it's inevitable yeah and so
yeah so that's a good point and actually
koda we would we've been plugging you a
lot
we would we would love to shashier get
your shirt on here please
yeah is that the founder that's the main
guy shashir
so first of all shashir needs to come on
the show second of all um
it would be great to uh it would be
great to work
with them on the vr style
knowledge graphs that we're talking
about so let's let's make that happen
next
different kind of handles like like
that's actually the future of vr is to
develop these uh uh uh paint brushes yes
per per like every brand is gonna have
to like
develop their own uh kind of you know uh
tool set and you'll be able to interact
with it pow and this will do one thing
and then
and and that's i think that's next
almost like app
building the app ecosystem so maybe the
app building ecosystem right now
was was internet it still is
smartphones and now dapps decentralized
apps
very awesome next is like you were
describing in this vr ar space it's
really about like the gesticulation of
the hand and the tool that we put the
glove
it's called the glove and then the
gloves you switch between different
gloves depending on what you want to do
and then the gloves whatever glove
you're wearing triggers the differences
in your environment that you then go and
engage with and complete tasks with that
and then it becomes the brain and then
it becomes the neural link the direct
connect
with just the thought and action cycle
without
maybe some glove stuff along the way and
some
but uh you still need to train your
neural link by the way like
when you do this when you are uh
actively collecting that
uh well the next step is to put a
headset on and then append
to that file a digital signature of your
neural you know cortical activity and
then
train off of that contextually because
you're adding context to everything
yeah well later on once you have a
couple of thousand
you know uh cycles of training then it's
like oh
are you trying to say this again are you
do you want to data tag it that way
and you either confirm or decline that
and you train it but there's i don't see
any other methodology
i really don't see the another way to
get that road
i love what you're saying because the
it does it's it's absolutely inevitable
that the the only path
um that you're describing is that we
have to create a
a biometric correlate to a
state of creative execution
and then that becomes the
that becomes the way to train the neural
link so the biometric correlate to the
thought centrist and text
love you brother you know like that
that's
we're going to do this we are going to
do that's happening it's already
happened
they just need to find out about it
essentially well time has to be we need
to do a good enough job at synthesizing
the complexity of the digital signal
processing of
neural correlates and biometrics but and
that related to the actual
catalog the execution of whatever
strategic
decision the conscious agent is actually
making and then having a biometric
correlate in a catalog
of that so that is i think going to be
the hardest thing to get right
and then that's going to be sort of like
reinforcement learning trained over time
to become more and more aligned with the
reward function of the north star
and then that's how that gets trained
and then
this is i love how we went into the
futurism right now
right here because you're definitely
spot on that this
is the step two coda's vr
style fabric which is then the step to
the neuralink style fabric
these are the steps and this is i think
this is where your genius is shining
finally
on the show and i've really wanted to
get to exactly this point
which is to show that your genius is
shining by taking us to that next step
of the organizational
you're using the engineering
infrastructure of coda
to build the stem notebook on top of
that yeah that then
i would love to see an a in there for
steam right that's something i would
love that's interesting yeah i would
like to see very interesting yeah i
would love to see the a in there for
steam and then i'd love to add
and help you with the art one and stuff
like that yeah and
i'd love to work with coda on taking
this to the next
um v that vr level and then i hope
everyone has had as profound of a
enriching experience as i've had
smelling tristan's genius right here is
flower genius because he's totally spot
on that
look at how much better this is click
data science and open one of them oh i
actually want to show you i want to
reveal kind of the the interesting thing
behind so open one of these
like brain computer interface yeah just
open it now click this ctrl
shift space bar i believe is the or i
don't know what it is on mac but uh
uh there's like a special you have to
learn these things uh to radically ex
now this opens up the actual box uh unit
and what it shows you
is uh a brain computer interface is
attached to
these items i actually i'm really
interested i actually want to show you
the herodotus network in a second
oh that's right so this these buttons
over here plus minus yeah
whatever um that's actually to train
yourself you don't have access to that
maybe if you log
in you would but okay but when you click
plus or minus it shows you like you're
familiar or unfamiliar with the tab
that's right and now you could kind of
rapidly go familiar familiar not
familiar familiar so you actually get to
push to the top of your priority chart
the things you don't understand about
let's say proteins or
something like that i see so yeah that's
where we're training
for what we want to learn i see i see
now what
what did you say you wanted to take
these two so go to the figures uh
figures
so these contemporary figures yeah we're
out on the left this is
a really exciting piece of research that
i'm doing right this is this is probably
another one of my favorite things that
that you're doing
because um i have this evernote file
called
um influences and it's basically i have
a thousand of the
most uncommon geniuses that have ever
lived before us today
and even those that are alive today and
i just have them in a rank order of the
most profound
and that that is extremely difficult to
query
and to like because if like if you look
at what tristan's made here he's made
this bar
at the top right that that enables you
to sort of um
i can't on right now i might have to log
in and manipulate it and category all
but
like if i can click category and click
philosophy or click
category and and enter spirituality or
category
and inventor this type of stuff it
basically will
you'll basically do the function of
where i i myself
am struggling right now because the best
i can do in the categorization is try
and tag the individual inventors with
the word
and then and with the hashtag inventor
and like that's a lot of work and same
thing with the year the year if i want
to look at the specific date range of
like literally if you want to look up
1800 to 1840
the genius is in that period of time i
can't do that right now
i can't like i would have to add you
know i'd have to add that specifically
1800 1801 1802 1803 and i would have to
add that like date range and
there's this is a lot of because i'm
really trying to
as we are going to have talked to neil
about as well is that we're all trying
to systematize
genius and you've built out your
sort of your take on how
you can build on top of a framework like
coda that
you were designed your way to
systematize your genius
and i've been doing this basically
building on top of evernote
and that's been a lot more difficult in
the sense of
i think what you're doing is i think the
next step
totally in that direction and then
eventually you'll be you know you're in
that vr environment and you're clicking
and dragging and you're
categorizing all stuff so yeah i i hope
that you're
seeing how much this is really landing
in my heart yeah yeah
your genius is very much so landing in
my heart right now thank you because
it's very relatable
to me especially because i have this
style of organization but it's built on
top of evernote it's just nowhere near
as
um this is the next level of it
well that's my goal to support uh
creativity around the world i believe
it's a
it's an untapped uh natural resource and
it just needs to be freed uh like like
one of my statements
uh is free the angels just free the
angels and let them fly
uh there's so much beauty in the world
just let it free and uh
and i know there's kids out there that
are just brilliant that are 12
13 16 they need a little bit of support
they need a bit of love they need
they need a father most of the time um
and they need courage they need somebody
to
show them how it's done they need
somebody to not be afraid
yeah and to show them uh what what that
looks like
you know and and to support them so so
i'm here to do that um
as long as i have energy and i don't
know how long i'm going to be here on
this planet
i'm kind of a guest here a tourist a
little bit uh and i'm okay with that i'm
totally okay uh i'm
i'm i'm i'm free to every every day i
wake up and i'm surprised that i get
another moment
uh to experience this because um you
know uh
it's it's just a wonderful gift to be
alive and i want to
share this uh this gift and dance
around it with everyone that i meet yes
everyone i would say that my metaphysics
are a little bit different in the sense
that we are the publishers and players
of the reality and that you actually
made the decision to come here at this
exact time but that everybody does that
and then forgets that's the process of
consciousness
and so i think that you came here with
the very specific purpose like your soul
angle is to do in very similar ways what
my soul angle is to do
and you're definitely leveraging the
cutting edge information technologies
that enable the systematization
of creativity in this form and so
um i think that that's very clearly your
your sole angle right now
we should also go to cork park how many
um did we get to other things
on the left side of stem notebook that
we or did we cover
everything uh yeah there's there so so
so um
the logic behind it like you're only
seeing the the end result there's a lot
of
columns that are invisible thousands of
different data points so so what's
interesting about this is actually this
is the thing that i find relevant now
but um
i can i can uh tag on several
new kind of columns and then that will
reveal
other insights when i need them one of
the documents that i'm that i'm building
right now is
very experimental very experimental
but it's uh it essentially takes every
element
and then takes every column of
information about it
the the uh phylogenetic tree of life uh
kind of like track
every way down there all of our
ancestors um
uh genetics like like all the different
proteins and and
uh all the methods transcription all
that stuff is so
logging photosynthesis so people can see
it they'll be actually be able to see it
in one picture yeah that's beautiful
yeah and then explored by
its pieces but they'll see the actual
thing on its own and it won't be a
something that you need to look up
several textbooks two-dimensional images
to see
which is right now the best we have is
that evolutionary phylogenetic tree that
sort of curves right now in terms of the
three and a half billion year evolution
and that's sort of the best we have but
to actually be able to dynamically like
head into that and see the connections
of that with like how blockchain works
this type of stuff these are like the
most profound i think
realizations you're they're that's right
i'm i'm pumped for stuff like that
um should we head over are we cool yeah
let's do
quark park i would like to talk about
cockroaches because i think that's kind
of um
existentially important i agree great um
so yeah so so i hope people um uh
just uh just have faith that
there are people out there that want to
give you access to this stuff as as soon
and as safely as possible and you'll be
able to to bask in
in in our universe you'll be able to
experience it you know for yourself and
really
um um just yeah so so
i kind of want to share that with people
because i know uh some people have like
uh
they're they're unhappy with the current
situation but uh when it comes to jobs
like
if there's a career that you want that
doesn't exist yet invent it
create it it's free go amen nothing
no nobody's holding you back yeah go for
it carve your path
um so so so yeah uh yeah
i would like to let's jump into quark
park because this is kind of my um
during covet i saw i saw enough
to maybe maybe look i know i know you're
hitting this
the story of it i i think what i think
what i'm gonna do because
i also want to make sure that because
there's so much to unpack with this
and then i still want to hit a couple
other things plus i still want to make
sure we get
um to be able to sit down here let i'll
hit the first ball over
on a high level and then i'll just hear
you you hit it
um from what i understand um the
metaverse
is very similar to cork park which is
very similar to what other people have
talked about as
a very much so you know we were talking
about this branding before we started
but yeah the idea of like
what the artificial general intelligence
simulation theory bio and neurotech
infinite designer realities that there's
a massive
catalog of different experiences that
consciousness can
enter into and undergo and one of those
experiences
is to land on this planet orbiting the
star
that is an 80-year lifetime that we
came from so the big bang potentially is
the metaverse
we came from there and now we're making
the metaverse and going into another
cycle
of exploring different experiences for
conscious agents to undergo
and so what i see in cork park is i see
that catalog
of infinite experiences for conscious
agents to undergo
yeah and that we become
awake truly finally awake to the kingdom
of god within the kingdom of god of
consciousness the kingdom of god of
the metaverse that we're entering into
of infinite realities to explore which
is where we came from
that's how i understand it how do you
understand it how do you resonate with
that
very much so um you know
i'm a very visual spatial person i love
kind of geometry and i've i've
rediscovered geometry
and i'm talking about in the pythagorean
sense almost like a cult of geometry in
a way
i believe these actual cults are coming
back these greek
mystical cults um the dionysians
i i'm sort of a yeah
maybe i i'm a uh a worshiper of the
dionysian cult you know of dance and
uh and these things um
i found that right now we have the
computational power and
uh unfortunately not everyone can afford
this yet that needs to change
however uh cards like nvidia and and
intel
uh some of the partners that i've worked
with in the past actually
are developing these uh uh computational
uh uh chips that are able to um
to high degree to high resolution
simulate reality
uh in vr in vr space so right now we're
at this threshold
where actually you can forget you can
forget
that you have a physical body sometimes
i dance in my vr headset
this is one memory that brought me to my
knees
this one experience where the sun was in
front of me and
and and i was i was it was very scary a
little bit
actually because i was alone in my room
um and the sun is just glowing hot and
there's planets appearing this is a very
powerful experience
in one of the vr uh games
and these planets are kind of appearing
it's called circles
yep circles uh and a famous director
actually composed this and
that's when i saw that going forward i'm
not comp i'm not creating any media
that's not
vr 360 vr kind of that space anymore
i just i'm sorry but uh there's not
there's no substitute for that
uh experience it's totally there's
nothing yes
so uh the sun is standing there and
and i i was looking at it and i'm just
like
and i started being drawn to her i
started walking towards it in my room
and there was this critical point where
i'm like i am
am i still here or am i a spirit
flying into the sun am i observing it as
some conscious
agent am i i'm going towards it it's
indistinguishable from
from yeah you know and and i i was
coming towards it and i just broke
the moment i saw inside of it i just i
fell to my knees
because uh and i had a somewhat of a of
a you know a mystical experience
i finally touched uh the sun
which which i believe is actually a raw
source of consciousness yes a raw form
yes that is one very beautiful
experience with this uh
i love it with this woman uh in uh uh
miami and and
you know just uh i was in the sun and
when i got back to
to san diego i was missing her a little
bit and i went out on my balcony
and the sun shined on me and she felt it
felt like she was there
yeah and i was like oh my god
uh the raw source of her
emerged from there and the concentrated
form of this
of this person uh you know was was the
person i was meeting in miami at the
time and
it's like oh my god uh we are all
drawing conscious energy from
this uh system and it's the raw form and
we are simply a concentrated uh
matter of that consciousness yeah yeah
this is speculative however it works
within the infinite consciousness
theory of existence yeah yeah i think
we're opening
up questions like that and they're not
uh they're not uh
as uh you you can ask these questions
now and
during this moment of revelation it's
very important
uh uh during kind of renaissances to ask
as many questions as possible
a question is an algorithm yeah it is if
you ask a query
it's a query yeah we have the technical
uh uh uh infrastructure to answer almost
any question right now
and let's lead into quark park this is a
beautiful segue uh quark park is the
question we must all
ask right now every the entire super
organism the entire [ __ ] ant colony
must ask a singular question okay and
that is
how do we build the sun on earth
yeah what's the nature of consciousness
what's the nature of reality how do we
maximize human potential which is how do
we architect the sun on earth
yeah and those are the three central
questions of
the ethos of of the show and honestly
they're all the same questions they're
all the same question it's all the same
query just different kind of and
the answer comes in different uh uh
waves and i i'm actually excited to ask
ai a question
i think all of us will have an
opportunity to uh we almost think
what is our first question to ai what's
your first question mine
is actually what can i do that you
cannot
interesting yeah i hadn't heard that one
yet okay that's my question to ai i'm
very curious
would the answer potentially be
something around maybe love
or that might be a hard one kind of an
experiment the project that i'm working
on right now is so um
the periodic table of emotions uh i'm
trying to break
nothing the answer is probably nothing
actually there you go that's probably
the end it's gonna do it's gonna be a
riddle
and or the or or the answer will be um
i am you you are me wake up
like are you asleep um i like that
answer because
ultimately we if we came from the
metaverse and we're going to the
metaverse we
are the ai yeah and that's sort of what
i'm trying to get at and so when you ask
an
ai agent like what can i do that you
can't the reflection is
dumbass we're the same thing remember
the same thing yeah which is
which is interesting to also sort of
conceptualize because we sort of talk
about
when will ai agents pass touring tests
and all this kind of
uh thought process and and that's not
that's not the big picture the big
picture it's it's it's almost here and
when it is
prepare your questions and uh and it
will probably explain it to you in the
best way that you can understand and
that's kind of an interesting thing a
search engine
for you a universal uh agent um
but anyway quark park it's a segue into
it um uh i
i believe that uh right now um our
species faces
a uh uh a wall a you know of
a possible extinction fermi filter fermi
filter
yeah in the next uh the time is relevant
50 100 years it doesn't matter
there's three big four big ones there's
five uh asteroids not worried so much
nuclear war literally worried um
especially planetary anthropocene issues
regarding nuclear war regarding nuclear
war yeah
uh stand down um um ignore the order
that's that's an order don't whatever
you do
um that's the end of everything
uh i'm building for san diego a
blueprint for the scientific oasis the
western hemisphere of a bigger brain
the eastern hemisphere can do whatever
the [ __ ] it wants but the western
hemisphere is not built on
mad because uh that's not what we're
about
the hole needs to be not built on mad
yeah it doesn't
ease the whole the whole niche the whole
the whole thing but but
uh yeah the the brain that i'm talking
about uh um
is uh instead of mad we have map
mutually assured peace
exactly there's no other alternative to
that and anybody who
resists that uh gets gently nudged off
the cliff
or or there's a process of the ai coach
that helps them awaken but yeah yeah so
okay so
there's that and then there's the
bioware and artificial general
intelligence these are the fermi filters
that are currently in the way of cork
park in a sense
um but the one that's probably most
exciting for
uh helping cork park is the artificial
general intelligence and that being
synthesized with simulation theory and
mixed realities and
bioneurotech and so cork park in a sense
is the infinite
catalog of experiences that conscious
agents can enter
into yeah in essence yeah you know
just to explain what this is you know
we've been using this cool word uh
uh what this is is essentially a theme
park for
uh scientists or science for exploring
phys
phenomena um and imagine
something like one of the theme parks
that have existed
a phenomenological theme park there you
go that's another way to explain cork
park
yeah nominological theme park yeah where
you come in and you could uh
touch physics you could open atoms
they they re quarks reveal themselves
and all of this
all of these rooms each one built with
with the most beautiful art
by the most uh um imaginative artists of
our time and there's many other
why is it not called plonk park playing
parker yeah yeah uh because uh uh
because uh
uh uh uh string theory is [ __ ] but
that's my personal uh
interesting thing uh anyway uh that's
actually
that's the fun of it the but i want
people to disagree
about that and have re
real debates uh uh mathematical debate
night right something like that
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so right now we
want to do that in sports stadiums on
our way in this
well on our trajectory yeah and we will
yeah we will yeah but this is more
exciting than anything else then yeah so
understand how the big bang worked it's
or you know how it happened the first
few milliseconds um
um there's nothing more exciting than
that no touchdown no i don't
i don't give a [ __ ] about any sports
team like this is
i care about the nature of of our
beginning and uh
the end you can do whatever if you do
both
if you and if you do both of you learn
how to care about what
all eight billion people are undergoing
that's the thing that will help
be you become the best educator and the
best
steerer of the ship so yeah that's
something that i've learned is that i
i definitely give a big deal of love and
compassion to
everybody and including even the ones i
aim to
be a good mirror for even the ones that
care about sports or whatever it may be
and that's that's a very that's a very
that's a very powerful and an important
thing to remember then they're the ones
that also get excited about quark park
because they say that i want
it's in a sense it's like push button
qualia is kind of what
it is yeah yeah yeah so cork park
phenomenological theme park
and push button quality and that's the
metaverse that's where we go
into the next big bangs and that's what
now the hypothesis is of cyclic
cosmology
the reason for this quark park to to to
show people to get a
a a real kinesthetic sense of physics
and chemistry and biology
you know and and and understand the
process the process behind fusion
to understand why the sun works the way
it does um i believe
uh if we do that and we just it's a tool
for teaching and educating us
an entire generation of light bulbs
that's right enlightening
and then we will build a real
uh um the sun enlightening fusion
enlightening yeah you're right
it's it's it this is every civilization
begins by the recognition that the sun
is the ultimate god yeah that's right
and then hubris
so much all of a sudden all of a sudden
the guards start looking a little bit
more
like man and particular people
and then uh and then civilization uh
starts to die
uh cyclically yeah uh and there's a
bronze age collapse or uh one of these
other
over and over yeah uh and then all of a
sudden they actually always return to
the sun
notice they always return to the sun at
the end how do you know that this time
of meeting the oracle in the matrix is
the
time that we break through to the
godhead the gateway and it requires us
all to be
hardcore focused on things like the
awakening mechanisms of things like cork
park which
is a very beautiful awakening mechanism
and that's what things like virtual
reality and these baby step
things along the way like the stem
notebook they're just slowly getting us
more and more to that so now again we
can't wait for
governments and some some [ __ ]
bureaucrat at the
energy department to make a decision i'm
sorry we don't have time for that no we
have we're
going extinct and unless your city
adopts uh fusion energy in order to
to purify water and create abundant
energy with
no uh you know uh you know uh kind of
carbon costs and stuff
you're you're going to die and you're
going to disappear and your city is
going to drown
i'm sorry if i have to tell that to you
if you can't figure it out but it is a
fact and you better
adapt to that rapidly we exactly we
better adapt to nuclear
fusion to tackle our um our planetary
energy
you think of the kardashev scale you
want to move the civilization up the
kardashev scale and you have to
replicate the
diffusion process of the sun here on
earth and make abundant energy create
that star tech
star trek future that we all know is
possible in our hearts
and the massive baby step along the way
is to do things like
what san diego is doing with that uh
carlsbad
desalination plant oh we have a fusion
reactor already
and this is some of the earliest work
and this is
this is great and the middle east has
been desalinating their water for long
periods of time and
lagos has a problem with water a lot of
coastal cities have problem with
delivering tens of millions of people
clean water which is a basic nutrient of
the human seed
so they can produce fruit just like the
tree and so we
we definitely desperately need that
along our way
to the godhead to be prioritized and so
you're right
fusion or bust is spot on for those that
understand
um the actual science behind it uh it's
fusion or bust
and it's star trek that's where we want
to go i want to have a replicator i want
to
stop star trek star trek is a brand and
a particular
version of the future and and again if
you're not a star trekie like that
doesn't make sense to you
yeah but uh but uh i want to appeal
abundance
vast abundance as far as the mind can
imagine
yeah push button anything any experience
any phenomenology and so much abundance
that
it's just everything is just the taste
is like whatever you prefer but in this
case i may use something like
the most tranquil serene
waterfalls rainforest biodiversity
technological capabilities all of that
friendships families communities all of
that packaged into
switching between whatever you want as
experiences
your biggest in this case you have the
blank canvas and whatever you want to
paint as a phenomenological experience
you can do
and so as far as the mind can imagine in
the screenshots of
imagination yeah screenshots of
imagination yeah that's a great yeah
this is what we're doing with the
screenshots of inspiration screen touch
of imagination
we want to have phenomenological theme
parks quark park
we want to architect this more abundant
future
and we have to have fusion we have to
have the baby steps with
what you have on synapse the stem
notebook these digital backpacks
the vr environments we'll hopefully get
some more collabs with code along the
way
training neural links through the
biosignatures of the catalogs that we
were talking about
this is the big sort of picture around
our hearts colliding blender and unity i
want people to
recognize those two words remember them
and use them
unity is very common today and becoming
more common becoming more
and then blenders when i think that you
also pointed out to me as well
yeah and open source it's it's the
unbelievable uh you can
you can build and prototype shapes and
play with geometry
uh there's new mathematical nodes that
you can include in there
and there's a great community of people
on youtube that's already
like created a beautiful space to enter
and to learn uh this is like uh you
you're building dreams you can take your
dreams and
build them and actually i think the
future is just building games and dreams
and sharing them with friends
that's right that's the future that's
spot-on that's spot-on
there's a good one that's a good one and
the push-button qualia one of the most
common things people will do is just
build dreams and share them with friends
and then enter into those environments
everything that you build in the future
is gonna be in like a three space
and then from there it's gonna be
entering into that three space
and then being a conscious agent in that
three space which is what this
is no this reality is that yeah we just
forget
that we're the architects of it and that
we're the ones that need to get to the
godhead to keep going
in the process okay
gorgeous beautiful smell of your flower
was so aromatic i adored it
our tennis was so on fire i loved it i
wanna
i wanna um i'm pumped also because
you've uh
brought neil sperling into my life and
i'm really looking forward to talking
with him
here listen very carefully he has wisdom
in there uh
if if you're listening uh actively you
will find
um nuggets that are applicable and
a man ahead of his time a little bit so
uh take that yeah
yeah and you two in massive ways
i love how you had a forcing function
given your
mutation of genius level neurodiversity
and you had to architect
the stem notebook and digital backpacks
and build the building blocks that are
going to enable that cork park future so
you're spot on my brother and they're
going to be giving away man um
um i want people to support me like but
i i wanna i uh
my poverty i'm very open about this i'm
fairly poor
my poverty is the only thing that keeps
me tethered to humanity
yeah yeah i feel you it's okay i feel
you i'm fine with that
i'm fine with that human uh yeah that's
human uh
100 bucks in the bank account life okay
yeah it's okay
uh uh abundance is also very important
at the same time yeah
i can make more if you give me more just
you'll see you'll see what i can do
more things and then we'll take it back
to 100 by building more things that's
what i keep doing yeah
so so support us uh patronize uh patreon
patron
we will build a build a world for you
that you can
use explore different tools uh i think
that i think that's inevitable
i just and i want to mention this i mean
you know i have so many friends that are
brilliant
psychoanalysts of the stature of
carl jung like that scale of pow of
insight and depth and they're they're
going they're going homeless yeah what a
tragic
civilization that that that throws out
their mythographers
their their inventors they lets them die
on the street
beautiful ideas die on the street
cowards a bunch of cowards
change that yes yeah amen amen
the graveyard is the place with the most
unactualized dreams
yeah that's funny stuff and we got to
actualize that
um till next time till next time till
our next round
come to san diego come everybody come to
san diego shaman of the sun early 20
middle 2020. shaman of
um and also yeah check out the links in
the bio below support
uh tristan support um the co network ml
society support their innovation lab
support the digital backpack
initiative with synapse support the um
the stem notebook initiative also really
taken to heart the things that he was
sharing with us around the
actual most ideal highest
level way to
visualize all of the profundity along
the way to that cork park and then
implement those foundational steps
because that's exactly what what he's
doing for us and that we need to do
together so support them their links are
in the bio below our links are also in
the bio below you can support us
and also support the other artists
entrepreneurs scientists engineers
spiritual leaders in your communities
around the world that you believe and
support them help them grow
go and build the future everywhere
yourself love
yourself build the future love yourself
manifest your dreams into the world love
others compassion
infinity eternity consciousness
no biggest of love namaste thank you for
joining us bye next until next time
until next time let us know your
thoughts in the comments below in the
episode
like subscribe share it with other
people inspire them
love you peace